Guten Abend, mein Name ist Kevta Göktas. Ich bin die zustandige Ästen für Sie.
Bevor wir zu Ihren Beschwaden kommen, lassen Sie mich ein paar Informationen über Sie notieren.
Okay, wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Irma Müller.
Könnten Sie Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam und kurz bestabieren?
Ich habe schon geschrieben, aber ja.
Ja, zur Sicherheit. Also der Vorname ist Irma.
Und der Familienname ist Müller M-U, also U-Umblaus, Doppel-L-E-R.
Ja, genau. Danke schön, Frau Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 37.
37.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 13.7.85.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 m.
8,60 m.
Ja, okay.
Und ich wiege 69 kg.
60.
Okay.
Was sind Sie für ein Büro?
Ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung, ein Büro.
Ein Büro?
Arbeiten Sie.
Und wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ja, ich habe zwei Kinder.
Danke schön für die Informationen.
Ja, Frau Müller, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Weißte Bescheiden haben Sie im Moment?
Ich habe so heftige Bauchschmerzen.
Das hat gestern Abend angefangen.
Und ich habe dann in der Nacht wirklich ganz schlecht geschlafen.
Und die Schmerzen werden eigentlich immer schlimmer.
Das hat angefangen eigentlich so wirklich mitten im Bauch.
Und das sind so richtige Grenze.
Und jetzt ist das so ein bisschen runtergerutscht,
dass es weiter nach rechts weh tut.
Ich verstehe.
Rechte Seite, ja.
Erst habe ich gedacht, ich kriege vielleicht Durchfall oder so.
Aber...
Keine Durchfall.
Das war eigentlich nicht.
Aber die Schmerzen wurden wirklich immer heftiger.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Und wie stark Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzgele von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leichten und 10 sehr starken Schmerzen entspricht?
Also ich würde schon sagen, ja, die sind bei 6 bis 7 so.
6 bis 7.
Könnten Sie am Ende dieser Schmerzen aufhalten?
Ja, das wird ja nicht so lange dauern.
Ja, ja, genau.
Okay, es wäre besser, ja.
Okay, und können Sie genau beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind?
Zum Beispiel sind Sie...
Also das sticht richtig, das sticht richtig im Bauch, ja.
Und eben, da krampfst sich alles so zusammen.
Krampf dich, krampf dich.
Okay, und füllen Sie sich fiebrig?
Fiebrig?
Ja, ich glaube, ein bisschen heiß ist mir.
Und ich habe auch so ein bisschen grünen Kopf, ja.
Grünen Kopf.
Und schlecht ist mir.
Also gestern Abend habe ich mich einmal übergeben.
Und jetzt ist mir wirklich sehr schlecht.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Aber nur einmal haben Sie erbrochen, ja?
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich habe dann auch nicht mehr viel gegessen heute.
Kein Appetit, ja?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay, ja, okay.
Frisch, hatten Sie gleich beschwerten oder erst einmal?
Nein, also solche, weil man klar, als Frau hat man mal Bauchschmerzen.
Nicht so, nee, das so, nicht so.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Maskellisten?
Oder brennende Schmerzen oder was?
Nein, das habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, okay.
Sie haben schon gesagt, im Mittelbauch sind Ihre Schmerzen aufgetreten.
Ja, und dann jetzt füllen Sie die Schmerzen im Jechteseite.
Ja, so im Unterbauch und auf der rechten Seite genau.
Unterbauch, okay.
Ich verstehe.
Möchten Sie etwas auch hinzufügen oder gibt es andere Beschwerden?
Nein, das sind eigentlich so die Hauptsachen, eben diese heftigen Bauchschmerzen, diese Krämpfe.
Und, und das mir so furchtbar schlecht ist, ne?
Okay, ich verstehe.
Okay, und Pramila, leiden Sie an krünchen Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Bullet-Hoch-Zurück-Sucker-Krankheit und so weiter?
Nein, so was habe ich eigentlich nicht.
Was ich habe, was ich habe, ich habe häufig so Husten, ne?
Also so ein bisschen chronische Quartite, sagt man.
Und ich habe ein bisschen ein Problem mit der Schildrüse.
Da habe ich eine leichte Unterfusion.
Okay, seit wann Schildrüse unter Funktion?
Das hat man so vor fünf Jahren festgestellt und ich bekomme da jetzt ein Türoxin-Tabletten.
Ja, in warscher Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Oh, das kann ich Ihnen jetzt gar nicht sagen.
Die Packung habe ich jetzt nicht mit.
Ich weiß nur, dass das immer untersucht wird und dann bekomme ich entsprechend die Medikamente.
Okay, danach können wir auch gucken, ja?
Das ist nicht schlimm.
Und chronische Bronchitis leiden Sie auch?
Ja, also wenn ich ein bisschen erkältet bin, habe ich immer langanhaltend Husten und so was, ja.
Aber jetzt geht es in Corona, bin ich geimpft und da bin ich nicht dran geworden.
Wie viel Mal haben Sie?
Drei Mal.
Auf gut.
Und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Als Kind sind die Mandeln rausgekommen, ja.
Mandeln?
Okay.
Kinderarzt, ansonsten gibt es keine Operation.
Wie sonst bin ich nicht operiert worden?
Okay.
Und in Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige oder böse Krankheiten, ich meine ihre Eltern, Vater, Mutter oder Geschwister oder ihre Kinder?
Also meine Schwester hat tatsächlich Brustkrebs, die ist ein bisschen älter als ich.
Meine Mutter ist zum Glück gesund und mein Vater, der hatte relativ frühen Herzinfarkt, aber hat den überstanden.
Also meine Eltern leben beide noch, aber der Vater hatte noch.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Einmal nicht.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Müller, besuchen Sie regalmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Ja, ja, diese Krebsversorgung und Untersuchung, das lasse ich regelmäßig durchführen.
Okay, waren wir die letzte Besuch?
Oh, im Frühjahr, ich gehe immer im Frühjahr hin, im März.
Frühjahr, März, okay.
Aber alles in Ordnung, ja?
Das ist alles in Ordnung, ja, ja.
Haben Sie Probleme, Regalbelutung?
Ja, immer mal ein bisschen.
Solche Schmerzen, wie jetzt, habe ich da auch mal erwartet.
Nicht.
Und die Regeln sind eigentlich ganz normal.
Ein bisschen vieler Schmerzen, aber nicht so stark wie heute.
Okay, und haben Sie Scheidenauspilus bemerkt?
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Nein, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Und gestern haben Sie nicht gut geschlafen?
Sie haben schon gesagt?
Ja, nachts hatte ich wirklich auch Bauchschmerzen.
Da hatte ich natürlich auch ein bisschen Angst, was wohl ist.
Und jetzt war es dann heute Morgen,
sodass ich gedacht habe, ich muss jetzt doch zu Ihnen kommen.
Ja, ja, Sie haben sehr gut gemacht.
Und früher aber, leider, leider sind Sie nicht
irgendwelche Schlafprobleme unter irgendwelchen Schlafproblemen.
Ja, aber normal kann ich gut schlafen, ja.
Okay, ja, und Appetit auch, ja.
Normalerweise ist es nicht so schlimm, aber seit gestern.
Ja, das ist jetzt, weil es mir so schlecht geht.
Da habe ich keinen Appetit, normalerweise.
Ja, es ist ganz normal.
Okay, und hat sich Ihr Gewicht in Nester seit Feier ein, Deit?
Ja, da achte ich eigentlich immer drauf, dass das so ziemlich stabil ist.
Dankeschön.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stüllgang?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Und seit gestern auch nicht, ja?
Ja, ich hatte das gedacht, dass ich vielleicht Durchfall kriege,
weil ich, als es mit den Bauchschmerzen anfängt, aber war gar nicht.
Okay, und haben Sie Probleme in Ihren Leben oder auf der Arbeit, die Sie belasten?
Nein, also das würde ich nicht sagen, da gibt es nichts, was nur um die Gerade dramatisch ist.
Okay, Dankeschön.
Und gibt es andere Medikamente, die Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf einnehmen?
Ja, wenn ich mal Bauchschmerzen habe, wenn ich mal Bauchschmerzen habe,
nehme ich Pancioprazol ein.
Weische Dosierung?
Ich weiß nicht, was da draufsteht, ich habe die Medikamente alle gar nicht mit.
Okay, kein Problem.
Ansonsten gibt es keine Medikamente.
Nein, also eigentlich nehme ich nichts ein.
Nein, ich habe nie geraucht.
Nein, das ist sehr gut.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, hin und wieder mal ein Glas Wein, wenn es, wenn man ein Gäste hat oder
abends, was zu feiern gibt oder so, ja, dann trinke ich gerne mal ein Glas Wein.
Im Sommer auch mal Bier, wenn es sehr warm ist, aber also jetzt nicht viel.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen? Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Drogen? Nein, nein, nein. Ich hoffe auch meine Kinder nicht, ja.
Ja, ich hoffe auch. Und sind Sie gegen alleinig etwas?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste. Ich habe bisher so nie etwas aufgetreten.
Okay, danke schön Frau Müller. Sie haben Schmerzen trosten.
Ja, haben wir diese Gespräche am Ende durchgeführt.
Danke schön. Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Ja, ich möchte natürlich schon ganz gerne wissen, wie es jetzt weitergeht
und was man gegen die Schmerzen machen kann und was das denn sein kann.
Irgendwie würde ich mich auch jetzt ganz gerne ein bisschen irgendwo hinlegen.
Ja, ja, okay. Frau Müller, das ist natürlich etwas, das ist ja sehr früh etwas genauer zu sagen,
aber es geht um Wun fortsatz. Das kann Wun fortsatz inzündung sein.
Aber zuerst würde ich gerne natürlich ein paar Massnahmen durchführen.
Zuerst möchte ich gerne Sie körperlich untersuchen,
Blutabnehmen, vielleicht eine Röntgenabdurmen veranlassen
und auch eine Ultrascheid-Abdurmen, ja, ich meine Bauch-Ultrascheid durchführen.
Dann können wir nochmal mit Ihnen darüber sprechen, ja.
Okay, muss ich denn da bleiben?
Ja, natürlich. Zuerst sollten Sie bei uns bleiben,
damit können wir diese Massnahmen durchführen können.
Aber zuerst bei uns bleiben und ich empfehle Ihnen, nüchtern zu sein,
weil...
Aber nicht auch, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie eine Kleinigkeit essen möchte, lieber nicht.
Ja, nein, wir haben einen Zugang, wir legen einen Zugang,
dann irgendwelche Probleme oder irgendwelche Flüssigkeit können wir auch bei Ihnen geben.
Das klingt vernünftig, ja. Okay, gut. Ja, vielen Dank.
Gerne. Das passt.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich habe... Ich denke gut gemacht, aber einige Fragen...
haben Kollegen andere Fragen.
Also die Spur ist ziemlich breit.
Könnte es sein, sind Sie schwanger?
Ja, genau, die Frage muss noch kommen, genau.
Also, das kann ich ausschließen, ja.
Was ist das?
Sie haben gesagt, ich stehe und kann fertig schmerzen.
Das heißt, wenn ich schmerze, oder...
Nein, wenn, ferme ich eigentlich nicht so sehr.
Also eher, eher das...
Ja, also so wie wenn man Durchfall hat eigentlich, so diese...
so Bauchkrämpfe, richtig.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie auch wieder weg?
So richtig weg hin tun die nicht, nee.
Sie haben gesagt, eine Wanderung die Schmerzen...
Straßen die Schmerzen in eine bestimmte Region aus.
Nee, Strahlen austrollen tun die nicht.
Ich habe gesagt, einmal Durchfall.
Wir sind...
Nee, einmal übergeben, einmal erbrochen.
Einmal über, keine Durchfall.
Okay.
Ich habe nicht gemessen, aber ich zue mich heißt.
Ja, das ist für mich kürzlich.
Gibt es 500 Euro für die Schmerzen?
Nee, das ist...
Also gestern nach dem Essen hat es angefangen, gestern Abend.
Nach dem Essen.
Haben Sie gegen diese Schmerzen etwas einmal Medikament eingenommen?
Nee, Medikamente habe ich nicht eingenommen,
weil ich gedacht habe, das ist normal so ein bisschen Durchfall,
aber das ist dann immer schlimmer geworden, aber ich habe nichts eingenommen.
Okay.
Danke schön.
Können wir anfangen, als als Geschebte?
Ja, fangen wir an.
Okay.
Hallo, Frau Oberarztin.
Ich würde gerne eine neue Patientin vorstellen.
Ja, auf wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Frau Irma Müller ist eine 37-jährige Patientin.
Sie hat sich wegen heftiger Spauchschmerzen,
Abdominalschmerzen seit gestern und Abdominalschmerzen vorgestellt.
Ihre Schmerzen waren am Anfang im Mittelpauch,
Mesogastrium, dann die Schmerzen haben im Unterbauch gerutscht, oder?
Wir waren da.
Sie sind gewandert in den rechten Unterbauch?
Ja, wir waren da, unter dem rechten Unterbauch.
Die Schmerzcharakter ist stechend und krampfartig.
Und die Schmerzintensität ist, oder liegt,
bei 6 oder 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Unsere Patientin klappt überall, naus sehr.
Und Emmaesis hat einmal erbrochen,
sie leidet unter Inappetanz und es gibt keine Ausstrahlung.
Sie fühlt sich ein bisschen pfiblich,
aber sie hat noch nicht ihre Körpertemperatur gemessen.
An Vorerkrankungen sind chronische Bronschitis und Hypothese bekannt.
An der Forsch-Operation ist die Tonselektomie in Kinderalta bekannt.
Kinderalta, okay.
Kinderalta bekannt.
Erststatus ist aktuell, liegen COVID-19.
In ihrer Familie ergab sich ihr Vater, hat ein Möckartinfarkt gehabt,
aber jetzt lebt er lebt.
Hat er überlegt?
Und ihre Mutter ist gesund, unauffällig,
aber ihre Schwester hat Mama Kartnon gehabt.
In gynecologische Anämnese ist unauffällig.
Es gibt regelmäßig Frauenbesuch oder Frauenarztkontrolle.
Die vegetative Anämnese, seit gestern,
er klagt über Schlafprobleme auch in Appetanz.
Ich habe schon gesagt.
Aufgrund der Beschwerden jetzt?
Ja, wegen der Beschwerden.
Normalerweise gibt es keine Probleme beim Schlafen
oder beim Appetit.
Stuttgart oder Wasserlesen oder Mission sind unauffällig.
Als Medikamente nimmt sie regelmäßig Erdrucksin,
aber welche Dosierung Mikrogramm weiß sie nicht.
Bei Bedarf nimmt sie auch Pantoprosol ein.
Als Noxel ist sie nicht raucher.
Sie trinkt sehr gelegenlich ein Glas Wein im Sommer manchmal ein Jahr.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde feinheit,
allergie, kein allergie bei ihr bekannt.
Die Anämnestischen Angaben durch den Amethystan auf Appendicitis hin,
als Differenzialdiagnose,
eine kommunische Anämnestin,
eine nephroditiazis.
Eine nephroditiazis.
Das ist ein abnexiales Problem,
das ist eine Abendicitis.
Soweit dann, Abklärung würde ich gerne manche Massnahmen durchführen.
Was machen Sie denn mit der Patientin als erstes? Da bin ich ganz gespannt.
Ja, zuerst natürlich, ich werde die Patienten körperlich untersuchen, dann Blutabnahmen.
Ja, aber ich hoffe nicht in Untersuchung, worauf achten Sie denn bei der Patientin?
Natürlich, abdominal. Untersuchung ist sehr wichtig.
Ja, ich würde natürlich, ich werde antasten oder ja, abtasten, ich schuldigung, abtasten.
Ja, ich nehme Latänisch, ich sage Latänisch, aber Riband oder Defens, ob
irgendwie Riband oder Defens, das ist nicht Latänisch vielleicht.
Können Sie das nochmal, ich habe das Akustisch nicht verstanden.
Ja, vielleicht, das ist Türkisch, Riband oder Defens.
Ah, Riband ist Englisch, ne?
Abwehrspannung, wo soll es sein?
Wie bitte?
Abwehrspannung.
Abwehrspannung, ja.
Ja, danke schön.
Ob irgendwie Abwehrspannung oder Loslastnetzen.
Loslastnetzen, das ist das Typische für die Appendizität, genau.
Ja, gibt es oder nicht?
Dann, Blutabnahmen ist sehr abnahm, Blutabnahme ist auch sehr wichtig.
Entsündung, Parameter, zum Beispiel, können wir diese Parameter überprüfen
und Röntgen abdäumen.
Ne, was machen Sie erst vor dem Röntgen?
Ich überlege, Blutabnahme habe ich schon gemacht.
Ja, aber was ist eigentlich die erste Untersuchung vor der Röntgenaufnahme?
Erst machen Sie Sono.
Ja, aber zuerst Röntgen habe ich gedacht, danach Sono, aber kein Problem.
Ich würde erst Sono machen, dann machen wir es ja nicht.
Ja, natürlich, Sonografie ist sehr wichtig,
unseren Verdachtstdiagnose nachzuwiesen oder andere nachzuweisen.
Also, ich denke, da muss man wahrscheinlich doch nicht mal mehr Röntgen,
wenn man im Ultraschall sieht, dass da freie Flüssigkeit ist
oder dass da eben eine Spälung ist, müsste man doch eigentlich sehen können oder nicht.
Ja, Sie haben recht, ja, zuerst, ja.
Ich würde gerne einen Sonofilter abdäumen durchführen, natürlich.
Ja, gut.
Ja, wenn sich Ihre Verdachtstdiagnose bestätigt, was wäre dann das Vorgehen?
Ja, natürlich, unseren Patienten sollte nicht stand sein.
Nicht stand bleiben? Ja, genau. Sie nehmen sich das schon auf, ne?
Ja, genau. Und eine Apandectomie.
Ja, aber was machen Sie zuvor?
Sie landet ja nicht so, ja, Sie landet wahrscheinlich relativ süß auf Tisch.
Antibiotikum und Analgetikum geben ja die Patrouille.
Also, und Sie haben hier schon angekündigt, dass Sie eine Infusion kriegen, ne?
Ja, natürlich, ja.
Genau, also sehr zügig die Infusion legen.
Zugang, ja, habe ich schon gelegt, ja, Zugang.
Und, oh, ich habe hier noch ein Stichwort, ja, restliche Darment-Lehrung,
wenn man dafür noch Zeit hat, ja.
Zumindest Mikroklist oder sowas, ne, dass der Darment leer ist, wenn man da dran geht, ja.
Okay. Ja, sehr schön.
Dann, ja, hätten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was bei Ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt
und dann sehen wir die Patientin wahrscheinlich im OP wieder.
Ja.
Zumindest aussieht, ja.
Okay, gut. Ich habe hier noch eine nicht ganz uninteressante Differenzialdiagnose.
Ja, sicher.
Das wäre, das wäre eine Extrauterien-Gravidität.
Das finde ich ganz spannend, die ist ja durchaus im Gebärfähigen Alter.
Sie sagt zwar, sie ist nicht schwanger,
aber das ist ja durchaus eine Möglichkeit.
Extrauterien-Gravidität, ja, okay.
Ja, und ja, hier ist noch ein Kron erwähnt, oder eine Darmpherforation,
also weiß ich nicht, also die ganze Darmgeschichte,
da kann natürlich auch noch was anderes sein,
aber an sich sind die Zeichen ja relativ eindeutig für den,
für den Blindarmen, ne? Ja.
Okay, also ich würde doch mal sagen,
Sie können Ihre Prüfung doch sehr entspannt entgegen gucken, oder?
Ja.
Ich denke, das ist, das ist doch sehr gut geladen.
Erst mal waren Sie super schnell
und Sie haben auch wirklich alle entscheidenden Sachen sprachlich
auch sehr gut rübergebracht.
Dankeschön.
An einer Stelle war es aber auch bei Ihnen.
Ja, bitte schön.
Wo Sie ein bisschen in Schlingern gekommen sind, sprachlich.
Was war denn das?
Mir so ganz schön.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, einmal, einmal war es in den Berichten
nicht so ganz glatt von der Sprache,
aber das war wirklich für einen ganz kleinen Augenblick.
Die Laucht, Runtergerüchte oder was?
Es geht um Runtergerüchte.
Ja, genau, wo die Schmerzen lokalisiert waren, genau.
Aber sonst würde ich sagen, war das, war das wirklich
in meinen Augen eine sehr schöne Präsentation auch,
sowohl die Anamnese als auch Präsentation.
Dankeschön.
Danke schön.